c'est un fond clair ce mec qui s'avance
pour défendre l'emploi les salariés de
general electric n'ont pas mobilisé
autant d'habitants qu'espéré malgré une
détermination intacte des manifestants
présents il ya des gens de toutes
conditions il ya des gens de toutes les
usines il ya des gens de tous les
services ont montré que l'ensemble de la
population les soutiens dans ce combat
celle du style économique c'est le
fleuron de belfort au resto mohadji
maintenant au caire c'est très important
il faut que tout le monde se mobilise on
regrette qu'il ait pas beaucoup de monde
est dans le coeur tout le monde est là
environ 1000 personnes ont défilé cet
après-midi une mobilisation très faible
par rapport aux 5000 espéré par les
organisateurs
le message n'en reste pas moins fort
dire non aux plans sociaux successifs
ces derniers mois aux 700 emplois déjà
supprimés d'autres postes dans les
branches hydraulique et charbon sont à
leur tour menacés
le moindre emploi qui est menacé par
general electric
c'est tout le territoire qui est menacé
c'est une belle force et tout le nord
franche comté qui est menacé c'est moi
qu'on veut faire vraiment en tant que
cette voie là et faire prendre
conscience que l'industrie qui a
structuré le territoire doit survivre
sans quoi notre territoire risquent de
devenir un ghetto économique
c'est la troisième fois en 18 mois qu'un
appel à manifester est lancé à la
population par la plupart des syndicats
de ji
plusieurs responsables politiques locaux
sont venus grossir les rangs du défilé
avec une ambition à terme trouver enfin
une solution durable pour pérenniser
l'activité oms absolument quoi qu'on
fasse tout pour que les compétences les
compétences qui sont à general electric
et qui sont en train d'être complètement
fabre et ses compétences restent ici
hein
l'enjeu c'est vraiment ses compétences
restent et qu'on trouve des
investisseurs qui viennent remplacer
general electric c'est ça l'enjeu et
c'est ce à quoi nous travaillons la
filière nucléaire a en tout cas quelques
motifs d'espoir des discussions à
l'elysée sont en cours en vue d'un
rachat par un consortium composé entre
autres de zdf